have you
found any studies that demonstrate
whether act works for suicidal ideation
or other
i think you call them distressors before
or but i'm not sure other because we
don't want to call them illnesses but
other and nor do we want to call them
disorders per se but issues other issues
maybe psychosis schizophrenia
derealization or
so
what's really interesting is
like i said there's over 300 randomized
controlled trials on act
and they range from mental health
conditions like depression anxiety
psychosis trichotillomania there's a
huge range of mental health conditions
it's been effective in a huge range of
medical conditions diabetes multiple
sclerosis
cancer
cardio car um heart failure a lot of
those
hiv
and in terms of the outcomes are
different right it's like getting back
into care or
cancer-related anxiety or
okay just to be clear you're not saying
employ act in order to induce your
cancer to a state of remission
no it's like for things related to it
like cancer-related anxiety or for in
the in the heart failure patients it's
improving behaviors that would
um improve actually your health
condition right
um migraines it's been helpful for
migraines because migraine is a very
similar condition right the more you
struggle that you're getting headaches
the more you're gonna get headaches
and the more you avoid life because of
fear of getting headaches the more
sensitive you become to things that
trigger headaches
and also it's been used in a range of
life things like chest performance
stigma
prejudice
um
rowing
so enhanced rowing sports rowing
enhancing sports performance for example
um
how about learning in general so like
for example in this channel learning
math and physics
i don't know if i've seen a study on
that that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
um
could you imagine how it could be used
to enhance learning or would it just be
if some anxiety was holding you back
from learning we addressed that and then
the learning i think so i think it would
be more like
how do you become more present focused
when you're studying how do you you know
not let anxiety and difficult thoughts
get in the way because
you can overthink you can worry so much
that it gets in the way of how you do
so you would address that part of it you
know
like in the medical conditions we
address treatment adherence
with our diabetic patients for example
because patients don't want to think
about their condition they won't take
their medications because the
medications remind them of how sick they
are right it's an avoidance strategy
and so you're telling them to face this
thing that's scary to them because
actually in the long term
it will help them with their condition
right
so there's a lot of treatment adherence
things that act works on because a lot
of
difficulty with treatment adherence is
due to avoidance it's uncomfortable it's
inconvenient it's anxiety provoking
um
act has also been used in works
workplace stress and burnout among
medical professionals
um
but you ask oh i know you asked me about
does it work for psychosis which
reminded me and now i'm jumping back
so act is listed as an empirically
supported treatment by
the american psychological association
and other
important boards for five conditions
for depression
anxiety
ocd
psychosis
and chronic pain
now it's been tested in
dozens of other conditions but to reach
the scientific rigor to be listed you
have to have a certain number of
clinical trials and they have to be from
independent labs and
you know so there has to it's um
it's a very rigorous thing to get listed
on that but
imagine it's actually listed
as an empirically supported treatment
for psychosis
and so yes it works for that more in
terms of
not reducing symptoms per se
but learning to live
with them
more effectively and productively
in the first study of psychosis
act reduced rehospitalization
and getting back to the question of is
acknowledgement a better term than
acceptance because acceptance has the
connotation that you should accept the
thought like go with it
believe it even
so it's not what it should be called
it's what works right it's what works
that said
i don't use the term acceptance in my
work you know it's scientifically it
works you know when we're writing about
it
but in the like day-to-day interactions
with my patients or with my clients i
don't use the term acceptance because
it's a very loaded actually actually
term like they take it as like just suck
it up and accept it you know
and that's definitely not the intended
message
acknowledge
is a much better term i think
the thing that acknowledge
doesn't get into i think
although it might i just haven't thought
about it enough but
um
acknowledge is a really good one
i think what willingness does as an
extra step
is
connects it to the value because
are you willing
to feel this way
or to have these thoughts
in service of something important to you
would you be willing to experience fear
and anxiety
if it means you'll be at your daughter's
graduation
would you be willing to experience all
the
difficulties
of graduate school if it means that
you'll get to do what you want to do at
the end right
so the willingness piece for me connects
it to the other side which is a critical
one
but certainly acknowledge is much more i
think compassionate than
except